hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast importance of sample
preparation and choosing the right gel
for SDS page it is presented by a local
bar PhD product manager for protein and
cell analysis at Thermo Fisher
Scientific I am Judy O'Rourke of lab
routes and I will be your moderator for
today's events we are delighted to bring
you this educational web seminar
presented by Lab roots and sponsored by
thermo Fisher Scientific for more
information about our sponsor visit
wwf/e sure com before we begin I would
like to remind everyone this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at anytime you
want during the presentation just click
on the ask a question box located on the
far left of your screen
and type your questions into the drop
down box it appears on the screen will
answer as many questions as we have time
for at the end of the presentation if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please use the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem this presentation is
educational and thus offers continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credit tab located
in the top right corner of the
presentation window and follow the
process to obtain your credits please
join me in welcoming dr. Tamar I will
now turn the presentation over to him
you
everyone and welcome to this gel webinar
where we will review sample probe tips
and gold key differences in pieces gel
chemistry's that can affect migration
straightness Shatner's and overall
performance of your protein gel
these are the ingredients that are
required to achieve an optimal gel
electrophoresis well with examples high
quality protein gels choosing the right
chemistry for your target application
and proteins using the recommended
buffers for that particular gel
chemistry using the correct gel running
operators and following the recommended
generally protocol which includes
information about current or voltage and
running time
the first part of this
about sample preparation or sample prep
in short for gel electrophoresis pool
sample prep has known to produce results
that are difficult interpret the sample
prep methods vary for different sample
bites and sample prep methods can
introduce incompatible substance for gel
electrophoresis
you
this is the list of most common
offenders when it comes to sample graph
excess amount of salt detergent and
lysis buffer will have a noticeable
effect on gel electrophoresis DNA or
nucleic acid contamination the type of
sample loaded and amount of protein
loaded the use of excess or incorrect
reducing agent loading different amount
of samples in adjacent wells having
empty wells adjacent example wells and
overheating of samples can all have
adverse affect on gel electrophoresis
okay so let's start with what happens
when you use excess salt on the right
the gel image shows the effect of
increasing sodium chloride or NaCl salt
concentration on electrophoresis now Lin
one is the unstained ladder and the lane
3 5 7 and 9 a 10 microgram of e.coli
lysate with increasing amount of sodium
chloride salt concentrations the 500
milli molar and 1 molar NaCl
concentrations they result in uneven
sample lane and Lane whitening which is
particularly noticeable towards the
bottom of the gel the high salt
concentrations causes increased
conductivity during electrophoresis that
affect protein migration and can result
in gel artifacts in adjacent lanes
containing samples with normal on
concentration to the extent that the
data from such lanes might be unusable
if your samples as has I salt
concentration either because of the
license of a composition or some other
reason you might have to perform
dialysis to lower the salt of a
consultation or you can precipitate your
samples and resuspend them in lower salt
buffer prior to electrophoresis make
sure that the salt concentration does
not exceed 50 200 milli molar final
concentration
you
protein precipitation by ammonium
sulfate a commonly used technique
similar to the gel on previous slide
using 10 microgram eco light sample with
increasing concentration of ammonium
sulfate consultations in three five
seven and nine resulted in viscous
samples that form streaks example Lane
edges so you can see that the bands are
not even like in lane number three
specifically lane number nine you can
see this prominent streets towards the
edges of the Lane and that is being
caused by higher viscous samples because
of this higher salt concentration
that is also Lane whitening this is also
particularly more visible towards the
bottom of the gel the possible causes
and solution are similar to what we
described in the previous slide
for Western blotting applications it is
common to use lysis buffer with 1% SDS
concentration this can be combined tired
depending on the sample type in a
diluted sample then higher volume is
loaded for wealth
the total SDS concentration can
significantly increase the total SDS
concentration is two and four percent
respectively in this 3 and 5 in this gel
that is on your right hand side
increasing IPAs concentration results in
the in whitening and uneven sample AIDS
as you can see Lea number 5 is much more
wider compared to lay number 3 and that
is twice as much STS concentration in
Lane 5 so these are side effects caused
by having increased amount of SDS in
your samples
similarly triton x-100 is also widely
used non-ionic detergent for lighting
cells to extract proteins
a buffer which is a commonly used lysis
buffer can have one to two percent
Titanic's hundred concentration in it
the gels that you've seen on your right
hand side raise seven eight and nine
there's increasing amount of Triton
expanded concentration and what you can
see with increasing concentration of
tigers acts hundred the limbs are
getting more white they're losing some
resolution towards the bottom of the gel
and they are uneven
the cause of such effect on gels is
because detergents are mixed myself with
an ionic detergent which is IPS which is
present in the gel and which migrates
down into the Dell this non ionic
detergent can interfere with the SDS
proteins binding equilibrium most of the
mammal invitations like Titanic's
hundred are worst when it comes to
interfering with SDS page so a rule of
thumb for a pH phase applications is to
keep the ratio of SDS to non-ionic
detergent at 10 to 1 or greater to
minimize this artifact of having to
disrupt the equilibrium of SDS and
protein binding the solution here would
be obviously to remove the excess
detergent and for this detergent in the
world columns are available or you can
use SDS page sample prep kits that could
help remove this excess detergent from
your samples
now Reba our radio immunoprecipitation
as a buffer is a common lysis buffer the
recipe for repurpose or is used in this
particular experiment is provided in the
right bottom corner the deeper buffer
has salt detergent using agent which can
all affect quality of gel one if the
final concentration of gel increases for
any reason as demonstrated on this gel
on the right that increasing final
ripple of a concentration up to four X
causes lanes to flare out at the bottom
resulting in wider lanes and straighten
this is caused by increasing the levels
of salt detergents and reducing agents
in the lanes which are all known to
affect quality of the gel the solution
is to concentrate the samples in repair
lysis buffer before loading them on to
the gel to avoid having to load higher
levels of this buffer for well
DNA contamination can have a significant
significant impact on sds-page the gel
demonstrate that protein samples can
contaminated with 1 3 or 5 point 6 mg
per mil in lanes 5 7 and 9 respectively
causes significant protein clumping
which results in narrowing of the lanes
and visible protein streaks during
electrophoresis DNA contamination causes
the samples to become very viscous that
can result in protein pumping and
streaking during electrophoresis
sonication sonication and other methods
that help share genomic DNA can help
reduce with quality and can minimize the
impact of DNA contamination on jealous
now loading wells with 20 30 or 40
microgram of total protein concentration
resulted in dance losing resolution with
streaking observed in in most of the
lens a 10 microgram of total protein
concentration per well the e.coli
lysates
in lane 2 or rat liver lysate in length
real salmon they produce sharp
well-defined bands with good resolution
increasing red liver like that load in
length is 9 and 10 that's much more
prominent effect on
band resolution and shrinking compared
to e coli license this demonstrates that
maximum amount of protein loaded per
Lane will depend on your sample type
however as a general rule it is
recommended to not go over point 5
microgram per bag or about 10 to 15
microgram of cell lysate per Lane so if
you are using a purified protein for
example you should not be loading more
than 0.5 micrograms per well because all
of that is going to be concentrated in
one band which is going to be a very
prominent bag but on a cell lysate
because you can have basically hundreds
of bands again every band should not do
more than 0.5 micro gram which is
usually the case so the total protein
lysate
when you are using a whole cell lysate
for that per cell or tissue the limit
would be about 10 to 15 microgram per
well
the reducing agent can be part of life
sample buffer and gel running buffer to
keep proteins and the reduced state
during electrophoresis as demonstrated
in the gel on the right increasing the
concentration of TTT 250 milli molar in
lane 5 500 milli molar in lane 7 and 1
molar in lane nine results in narrowing
of the lane and creates a shadow at lane
edges it is recommended that the final
concentration of reducing agent should
be less than 50 million bowler for BT
key and teasy and should be less than
2.5 percent total for the drama capital
is enough
now different reducing agents can have
different impact or total integrity
combined with the heating temperature at
time the image on the left is the new
based business gel from invade region
with various sample graph conditions the
link to has recommended sample prep
condition for loop age which includes
mixing the sample with mutate sample
buffer and addition of 1x new page
reducing agent which is essentially DDT
and boiling the sample at 70 degree
Celsius not 100 but 70 degree Celsius
for 10 minutes this provides optimum
protein denaturation and reduction for
distressed gels under this optimal
sample graph condition as demonstrated
in layer 2 there is very minimal sample
degradation and protein integrity is
maintained however use of x-tra which is
the pilot criterion XT reducing agent
instead of dtt in lane 3 and boiling the
samples for 95 degree celsius for 5
minutes as recommended by powdered
sample graph protocol reserves
insignificant protein degradation the
use of tracer icing sample buffers with
50 milli molar d TT and boiling the
sample for either 95 degree Celsius for
5 minutes
or 85 degrees celsius for 2 minutes
the using sample degradation
significantly as shown in Lane 5 & 6
respectively the image on the right
shows that the effect of sample prep on
protein integrity then using a
displacing gel compared to Victory's gel
the trill glycine gel shows more
degradation but the choice of sample
buffer reducing agent boiling
temperature and boiling time as a big
impact on protein integrity and
degradation levels
TCP or test to carboxy 514 is the
reducing agent present in valid
criterion extreme reducing agent
this slide shows different prep methods
using TCP and its impact on sample
integrity link to has recommended
protocol for the paid mistress gel with
new patient Okafor's and one activity
followed by boiling the sample at 70 C
for 10 minutes
Lin 7 8 & 9 demonstrate that heating the
samples and presence of by OS X T
reducing agent which contains gcep
results in significant protein
degradation
this slide demonstrates that we're using
agent TTP or try and beautiful seen a
different concentration is equally
effective as TTT in preserving sample
integrity however again power HT
reducing agent in lane nine results in
significant sample degradation so
choosing the right gel and the right
protocol for reducing your samples and
denaturing your samples is going to play
a vital role in how much you are able to
preserve your precious samples and avoid
sampling relation
this is a summary slide for all of the
sample prep data that we saw today you
will have access to this webinar and
this slide would help to provide an
overview of issues associated with
sample prep and their potential
solutions
this is protein gel electrophoresis 101
about that list of frequently used types
of protein electrophoresis as you know
page still stands for polyacrylamide gel
electrophoresis in an Edith page
application adding detergents like SDS
are not added to any of the buffers
resulting in the charged proteins being
separated according to their native
physical properties in an electric field
SDS creatures sodium dodecyl sulfate
page SDS is an ionic detergent and when
added to gel electrophoresis buffers it
denatures proteins and binds to the
deleted proteins
providing a uniform negative charge to
all proteins which facilitate separation
according to size only as shown in the
schematic to the right the SDS detergent
in presence of reducing agent can
separate the two subunits of a protein
which are held together by disulfide
bonds the using isn't likely to kill or
beta-mercaptoethanol can reduce
disulfide bridges to achieve better
denaturation the negatively charged vs
molecule then binds uniformly to entire
protein which results in separation
according to the size of the protein the
smallest subunit 8 migrates faster than
the biggest subunit b thereby creating a
size base separation on the slab of
polyacrylamide gel
okay so in the next few slides we will
review the different Dell chemistry's
that are available in precast gels and
the specific advantages and
disadvantages the two most widely used
gel chemistry's at risk lysine which
uses traditional lammily buffered and
mistress chemistry
the other two specialized gel
chemistry's are productive gels for
separation of large molecular weight
proteins up to 500 kilo Dalton and
pricing that is specialized for
separation of peptides and small
molecular weight proteins as small as
two point five kilo Dalton
let's take a quick look at the buffer
system of gel electrophoresis
the continuous buffer system utilizes
the same buffer in the gel and the gel
running buffer the discontinuous system
which is utilized by most commercially
available gels as a different gel buffer
and the gel running buffer it has at
least two gel layers of different pool
sizes and as different buffer
composition for the stacking gel which
condenses the protein sample into a nice
tight band during electrophoresis and
the separating gel which is responsible
for creating the size based separation
of codeine samples
this slide provides a quick summary of
the discontinuous buffer systems
utilized by the three most popular gel
chemistry
you
the truth pricing system includes twist
and chloride ions in the del buffer
which has a pH of 8.7 the running buffer
ions I press glycine and ionic detergent
SDS with pH of 8.3
importantly the gel operating pH for
Chris glycine system is 9.5 so when your
protein is migrating to a tryst life in
jail it is experiencing this 9.5 ph
throughout the gel run therefore this is
a very alkaline gel operating
environment for your protein the common
ion in the system is stress which is
present in the gel as well as the
running buffers now the business system
includes districts and chloride ions in
the gel buffer which is the pH of 6.4
the running buffer ions are twist mes or
mods and ionic detergent SDS with pH of
seven point three so importantly the
generating pH for district system is
seven so this is a neutral pH
environment and when your protein to run
through a bit stress gel they are
preserved better because they are not
exposed to alkaline or acidic pH
environments while electrophoresis so
the neutral gel operating environment
helps in getting better resolution as
well as preserving the sample integrity
the three faceted system includes prism
acetate ions in the del buffer which has
a pH of seven point o-- the running
buffer ions are press pricing and ionic
detergent HTS with pH of 8.3 the del
operating pH is eight point one which is
slightly alkaline but not as much
compared to the crystallizing system
in the next few slides I'll discuss the
different Dale demonstrates of precursor
cells and the that advantages as we have
discussed already the mistress gel
chemistry as a neutral pH operating
system which plays a vital role in
minimizing protein modification and
protein degradation thereby preserving
sample integrity
since business gel chemistry is
comparatively the less reactive
acrylamide the business gels have a
shelf life of up to 16 months at room
temperature at replacing gel can't be
stored at room temperature because of
its higher the activity and is
comparatively shorter shelf life it is
also known for quite some time now that
the neutral pH environment during
electrophoresis improves protein
stability which enables sharper band
resolution and accurate results
this slide shows
thousand of the same samples which are
purified protein kinases implicated in
cancer loaded on Invitrogen poor
districts as well gel and by our
crystallizing TTX gel since old mistress
gels have neutral gel running pH
environment the sample is the integrity
is preserved and protein degradation if
any is very minimal however with bio apt
eggshell multiple degradation bans are
detected along with the full-length
purified proteins this demonstrates that
the business chemistry with neutral pH
minimize minimizes degradation in
students elders
the principal chemistry is specialized
for optimal protein separation and
transfer of high molecular weight
proteins up to 500 kilo Dalton in size
if you are working with high molecular
weight proteins like EGFR bsea
or some membrane protein this is an
ideal zero chemistries for such
applications migration charts are
provided by all precast gel chemistry
vendors and they are a great resource
and deciding which particular gel
chemistry or gel percentage within a
chemistry will be optimal for your
protein offenders since this acetate gel
can separate the high molecular weight
proteins better it is able to move this
bigger proteins more towards the center
of the gel and they are not all stacked
at the top near the stacking gel which
significantly improves the transfer
efficiency the image on the right shows
detection of EGFR receptor
at a using lytic concentrations from
left to right the new page case acetate
gel on the top shows significant better
transfer efficiency and sensitivity of
protection compared to trigger icing gel
at the bottom which is not an optimal
chemistry to detect high molecular
weight proteins
on the other hand if your interest is in
protecting low molecular weight proteins
and peptides you should use the pricing
chemistry that is optimized for
separation and transfer of low molecular
weight proteins as demonstrated in the
migration charge the Triton gel enables
the smaller molecular weight proteins
like gasp a sub units to be optimally
resolved closer to the middle of the gel
compared to the truth lies in chemistry
as seen in the image on the right the
knowledge twice in gel on the top
provides a very distinctive separation
of the cleaved caspase-3 subunit
compared to the bio TGF gel at the
bottom
additionally smaller molecular weight
proteins experience very high blow to
effect during transfer process which
means that the smaller molecular weight
proteins are plastic passed
PVDF or nitro cellular nitrocellulose
transfer membrane and that lost
resulting is non optimal transfer
condition the ion concentration is
significantly higher at the bottom of
the gel near the diaphragm and therefore
this area experiences disproportionally
high current during transfer which
causes this local effect the price in
gel provide separation of the smaller
molecular weight protein closer to the
middle of the gel by preventing the
growth effect to a much greater extent
and which results in improved transfer
efficiency as seen on the pricing gel
over here
the tooth lysine chemistry
the most widely used air chemistry and
is used for a broad range of protein
separation it does have high alkaline
operating pH since trick lysine is a
very reactive gel chemistry that results
in protein modification due to chemical
alterations and reoxidation of amino
acid as discussed previously
it can cause band distortion loss of
resolution or increased background
giving Western detection because of
protein degradation bands that are
recognized by specific antibody against
the target protein
we understand the trick lies in
chemistry has its limitation and we
strongly recommend that it should not be
used for every application in your lab
the one-size-fits-all approach is really
not optimal or efficient when it comes
to selecting a precast gel for your
research application having said that we
have worked hard to work on some of the
limitation of prescribe in chemistry
while utilizing its inherent advantages
the Novak's wedge well drill glycine gel
is designed to provide excellent welders
vendor solution sharpness and staining
efficiency compared to buy order PDF gel
you can see better separation of
multiple protein bands in the life phase
and the no HP detail also shows
literally less protein degradation of
purified protein the protein bands are
sharp and straight and does not show the
smiling of advanced particularly in the
first of the last Lane which is very
visible in bowel tgx Joe
with all this background information on
their chemistry and SAP application we
can answer this question of which L is
right for your specific research
application this table provides a quick
overview if you are working on
applications like post translation
modification which includes tyrosine
phosphorylation or sealing
phosphorylation or threonine
phosphorylation are you working with
downstream mass spec applications for
your target protein or your target
protein is in low abundance
this requires maximal sample integrity
then you should choose the distress gel
mistress gel will not only help with
preserving sample integrity and reducing
the gradation but it also minimizes
protein modification during
electrophoresis that can have
significant impact on downstream mass
spec applications if you are working
with high molecular weight proteins
anything 200 kilo dalton and higher the
recommended gel is the new page trace
acetate gel that will provide optimal
separation and transfer of high
molecular weight proteins that by
increasing sensitivity of detection
different western blotting if you are
working with low molecular weight
proteins anything particular darker than
under the recommended gel is tri-c the
Tyson gel that is designed for optimal
separation and transfer of smaller
molecular weight proteins and dissolves
with proteins
towards the middle of the gel thereby
preventing or minimizing the growth of
effect giving transfer that impacts the
small molecular weight proteins
if your application requires the jews of
non denaturing condition or native
separation we offer material options and
mistress is glycine excuse me and please
acetate chemistry
we also offer options in whispers and
crystallizing chemistry for isoelectric
focusing and two dimensional
electrophoresis experiments for Proteus
activity application we also offer
designer Graham gems
our website has some very useful
resources that you can download
including technical handbooks for
electrophoresis transfer and detection
that is also an interactive gel
collection tool that will help in easily
deciding the right gel chemistry for
your research application
thank you for attending this webinar
today and providing me the opportunity
to highlight some of our key product
advantages we do have time for a couple
of questions and we'll be happy to
answer them now I will respond to all
the questions we have received today why
an email and in terms of time if I can't
get to all of them today thank you
thank you
or for that informative presentation we
will now start the live Q&A portion of
the webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop down box
located on the far left of your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click on the send button will answer
as many of your questions because we
have time for so let's get started our
first question is can customers use
their electrophoresis buffer with
triskele icing precast gel from thermo
Fisher Scientific
yes the answer to that if I understand
this correctly the question is with
precast gels can you use home-brewed
tell running buffer so the answer to
that is yes obviously you have to be
mindful that you are using the right
buffer for the right chemistry so for
example trace glycine gels there is
stretch glycine running buffer if you
home through that buffer that's
absolutely fine but if it is the best
race gel as you have to make sure that
you are using the business running
buffer in that case so all of our
precast gels we we have ready to use
running buffers but at the same time
they are compatible with the home brew
running buffer as well as long as the
right recipe is used
great thank you the next one is
sometimes the protein bands in some of
my gels are not straight and
well-defined but are irregular or wavy
what can cause this
so yeah that's that's a good question
the as we discussed today right the
sample prep again it's an important
consideration for any successful gel
electrophoresis or an ideal gel
electrophoresis run so having your dance
baby can depend on multiple
contamination that can be introduced
during a sample preparation you know DNA
is known to cause dance to be in a V
shape or you know salt concentration
would cause a band to appear a little
bit squiggly so you know it's like we
discussed today it is important to make
sure that such contamination are either
removed or kept at a minimal to avoid
such artifacts during a gel
electrophoresis thank you next one is
can I run reduced and non reduced
protein samples on the same gel
so yet typically we do not recommend
doing that for some reason if you have
to run reduce the knowledge you sample
on the same job you know it's important
that you don't run them side by side the
reason being that can always be a little
bit of spillover and then the reduced
sample can compromise the integrity of
the non reduce sample so it's possible
preventing them on the same job but if
you have to then definitely don't run
them in side by side in next lanes to
each other thank you next one is I
sometimes get v-shaped protein bands
while running my gels what might be the
reason behind that
see this is again a question similar to
the one that I just answered about not
getting bands that are sharp straight
and flat a v-shaped band in particular
is caused more by DNA contamination as
opposed to salt or other contaminants so
they're you know typically very bean
shaped then it has to be because of DNA
contaminant most likely so you know you
should either sonicate your sample to
share the DNA that might be present as
you can do an ultra centrifugation step
2 to them you know eliminate the DNA
from your solubilized proteins and that
should help improve your band quality
thank you next one is sometimes I get a
blue wave with my gel loading died near
the bottom of the gel what causes that
I so that is that is it happens in
especially with pre-cut gels it does not
happen that frequently but it does
happen occasionally and the prominent
reason for that is your sample buffer
can get diluted for multiple reasons one
of the reason can be while preparing
fresh one example buffer for some reason
it's less than 1 X right so for example
if you add a little less buffer so that
it's really not 1 X so that can result
into a dilute sample buffer during
electrophoresis which can cause the wavy
die print or in some instances you know
customers to reuse the gel running
buffer the problem with reusing the gel
running buffer is when you have fresh
running buffer your ion concentration is
1 X and when you run everything is in
good proportion now when you are losing
it the buffer ions are depleted so you
don't know to what extent they are
depleted though right and it can vary
between every run now with a depleted
sample buffer your electrophoresis
conditions are not optimal and towards
the end of the run that can cause some
of the lanes to run faster compared to
others with results in this wave which
can be seen at through a diaphragm so I
think to avoid that you know always use
fresh running buffer and while you are
diluting your running buffer you know
pip pay close attention that it is truly
1x and it's not diluted in making your
buffer process good thank you I would
like to once again thank dr. Kumar for
his presentation would also like to
thank a thermo Fisher Scientific for
making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast we
available for on-demand viewing through
September of 2019 please share with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event that's all for now thank you
for joining us we hope to see you again
soon goodbye